aaron savali has taken them out and
ricky
he really impressed tito and the staff
not only
back in goodyear and early spring
training but what he did in summer camp
as well
swung out and missed and aaron cevalle
strikes him out to start the afternoon
two down with mon kata at first
third ball got him looking beautiful
pitch
by aaron savage his second strikeout of
the inning cesar hernandez off to a good
start he's gone four for 12 at the plate
kept his hands back nicely and he's
gonna punch that one into right field
four lead off single so lindor switch
hitter batting left-handed
he got the fastball that time and smoked
it deep right center field and goodbye
francisco lindor puts the indians on top
two to nothing with his first home run
on the year he came back with a fastball
and lindor was
sitting on it now the wind and the 2-2
swing and a mess strike him out a few
years ago and he
he mentioned his name and he was just
getting into the minor league system he
says where do you see this guy
and it doesn't take long well aaron
cevalle says where do you see me he has
struck out
four of the first seven bradley zimmer
leads off for cleveland
here in the second
high fly ball deep right field back his
angle
on the track at the wall goodbye home
run for bradley zimmer
the indians have hit home runs in each
of the first two innings and that was
about as high a home run
the seven of the first nine hitters
tell you what he's not wasting any time
he is just pounding the strike zone and
if you are
timing the pitch you see the ball hang
in there crush it
now the 1-1 is in the air to right
center field hit
pretty well backing up now as johnson
turns the wrong way and that ball's
going to be gone into right center field
tim anderson connects and a home run
brings the white sox a little bit closer
the first of the year for anderson makes
it three to one cleveland
now he's ahead of a mowing two and this
is the way you want to face moncado
swung and misty got him on three pitches
what a job by savali daniel johnson two
on one out one ball one strike count
and he smacks one up the middle
basically boy coming around third base
santana will have to stop
daniel johnson has his first major
league hit and the indians have loaded
the bases in the third
bradley zimmer homer to off the starter
dylan cease
zimmer goes the other way left field del
monaco race again he won't get it over
drop for an rbi single and the indians
lead is 4-1
as santana comes home and a beautiful
piece of hitting by bradley zimmer
his second hit of the game three and two
from savali
jose gets a piece of it to left field a
good piece of it back to the track and
the wall
and that ball kicks off the fence so
jose abreu
throttles down into second base with a
lead off fourth inning double
chased it up the ladder and a good job
by aaron cevalle to get a key strikeout
keeps abreu at second base
and that is seven k's for savala and the
bases
are loaded right back to him savali
to perez for one down to first he didn't
get there
garcia with a bouncing ball to santana
the underhand flip
in time inning over what a job by somali
one down for tim anderson oh yeah
tim to right field he's got a home run
now he's got a gapper
peeling away from first and a one out
double now
second and third one out this inning
[Applause]
jose on the ground to shortstop it'll
get a run home
and the socks make it four to two
struck him out looking you don't like
the last one well how do you like this
one
eight k's for eric somali a career high
eight strikeouts for savali
now the one-two
good night that's strikeout number nine
for savali and there are two down
in the sixth three and two
in the air left field ramirez well
struck deep to left it goes
and all the way back at the wall nikki
del monaco makes the grab
ross says thank you very much james
karen check coming on to pitch
the seventh inning for the indians
anderson went fishing but the ball gets
away
struck him out looking boy that was a
pretty
curveball by james karencheck and
mankata just could not pull the trigger
and dubrey awaiting the payoff pitch
swung
on it miss he went up the ladder and
struck him out with a 96 mile an hour
fastball
closer brad
he got hit harder last year hand did and
he got hit hard right here
ta deposits one off the wall and left
and the tying runs coming up
on a lead off double in the third hit
for tim anderson that will bring up
yasmani grand all
oh one granddad left side and through
base hit tim's around third
he scores and the socks are within
around yes monty
drives in his first sox run and you got
a guy with 415
career home runs 52nd all-time in
baseball
at the plate edwin encarnacion
struck him out looking oh he took a
breaking ball over the outside part of
the plate
and brad hand closes it out cleveland
hangs on for a one-run win over
chicago in the opener of the series in
game one of this doubleheader